in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Joe and
Megan are with us hey guys how are y'all
Hey all right welcome welcome where you
guys from Lexington Kentucky welcome to
Nashville
good to have you very very well done so
you're here to do your debt-free scream
yes we are
I love it how much have you paid off
well under your plan we paid off
forty-one thousand four hundred and
forty-two dollars since 2011 so in five
years yeah I guess so
okay making what kind of income during
that time I started out about a hundred
and twelve thousand mm-hmm and now we're
hoped to finish this year making about
150 total come on good for you what do
you guys do for a living I'm a network
engineer and I'm a nurse okay very fun
good so what kind of debt was the forty
one thousand that was student loans and
car payments mm-hmm and before we found
you we had paid off thirteen thousand in
credit card debt over three years mm-hmm
and then there was kind of a nice period
our income and improved and we had saved
up some money and we went on some couple
nice vacations and their savings went
down that was fine but what I noticed is
we were leaking about $200 a month every
month and I was like well we're just
gonna end up back at zero and whether it
takes 10 years or 20 years we're not
getting anywhere mm-hmm and at that time
I was doing a lot of driving with work
and I found your podcast and I listened
to the debt free screams and loved them
and then I finally heard the one that
really turned me was the legacy journey
had a bunch of people call in who had
done these debt-free screens and now
there were 10 20 years on I listened to
that podcast four times in a row and I
got home ordered the book read it over
fourth of July weekend and then signed
up for a class at the YMCA and told her
clear door Tuesday nights we're doing
this so Megan you kind of didn't have a
choice you just said you're doing no we
didn't have a choice at all okay so was
it bad or did you enjoy it oh I enjoyed
okay and so if you guys worked on this
together yes yeah okay yeah what what
really set it off was back in 2008 I
lost my job and we got her got around to
tax season got her tax return and we
paid off a credit card because we always
said stay in good good relationship with
a credit company Ida had this credit
card 12 years and we paid it off the
next day I went to buy gas and they had
shut my card down and I called them and
they said well we feel you're too big of
a risk to go back into debt even though
I just paid them $2,500 hmm and I'd
heard a term called pig biting mad I was
pig bite mad that day not heard that one
that's good I like it it's a little
scary but that's pretty mad which
company was that that was our friends at
Amex
Oh American Express I love those people
he says sarcastically okay very cool
well congratulations how does it feel
just wonderful to be debt-free wonderful
very good so you guys decided to make
the trip from Lexington down here to do
the debt free scream yeah why did you
decide to do that we had been in
Nashville once about five years ago and
we liked the towns okay and an excuse to
come to Nashville yeah that'll work I'll
take it I'll take it very good I'd made
the speech every day to my steering
wheel for three years you're not the
only one brother very cool well I'm
proud of you guys congratulations thank
you we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's retire inspired book signed by
him which is the next chapter for you to
build wealth and live like no one else
and later give like no one else you'll
be in a great position very proud of you
all right it's oh and who's the kiddos
give me their names and ages this is our
oldest mackynzie mm-hmm this middle son
Alex and the youngest ones here is
Carson
okay Carson Carson are you ready to do a
debt-free scream are you ready yes okay
good very cool one little story she got
a job last year mm-hmm and I asked her
how much he had in the bank and she said
I got about $1,000 at the time I was
like wait you got $1,000 in the bank and
you don't have any death I was like you
beat me to be in debt-free
well that's good she had a head start
though she's watching you guys win
watching you guys make good decisions
very cool all right it's Joe and Megan
and the crew from Lexington Kentucky 41
thousand dollars paid off making 112 to
150 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream you guys
way to go way to go way to go that is
awesomeness excellent job
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income on a $500,000